Isle of Dogs was directed by Wes
Anderson and features the voice talents
of Edward Norton Bill Murray Jeff
Goldblum and many others it takes place
in the fantasy city of mega Saki Japan
where a viral outbreak of snout fever
has caused the corrupt mayor mr.
kobayashi to banish all dogs to trash
island when a boy named Atari ventures
to the island searching for his
long-lost dog spots a pack of mangy
mutts joins him on an adventure to
locate his missing dog Wes Anderson is
no stranger to stop-motion having
directed fantastic mr. Fox which was
charming and gorgeously rendered but
with Isle of Dogs virtually everything
about the technique has been improved
while 3d animation has reached stunning
new heights hand-drawn and stop-motion
will always hold a special place in my
heart there's a rough around the edges
feel to almost every shot it's obvious
that a painstaking amount of hard work
has gone into each and every single
frame Alexandre des plots score propels
the film along with a steady pace
creating a surprising amount of suspense
as well some scenes were actually
riveting and a lot of that can be
attributed to his wonderful music in
typical Wes Anderson style the actors
are almost self-aware in their delivery
the line readings feel idiosyncratic of
the stars themselves almost as if
Anderson is knowingly allowing the
actors public persona to seep through
for instance every line from Bill Murray
or Jeff Goldblum feels almost
tailor-made for them for their style
this can sometimes be a distraction but
a minor one Bryan Cranston's performance
as chief the stray dog who prefers
eating trash over puppy snaps is a real
highlight the amount of visual wonder
present and I love dogs can be
staggering looking beyond the work
behind the stop motion technique
Anderson composes beautiful images as
usual he loves symmetry and that
couldn't be more clear with the
perfectly balanced shots one reoccurring
image that has stayed in my mind
is the silhouette of an unknown dog in
the distance one that chief says has no
scent while all of Anderson's films are
visual delights Isle of Dogs is one of
his most gorgeous sometimes this story
turns to excessive flashbacks that halt
the progression of the film damaging the
pacing this can cause some sequences to
feel a little uneven there's also an odd
choice to not provide English subtitles
for the Japanese language scenes and
instead these scenes are either narrated
in English or literally interpreted by
another character voiced by Frances
McDormand this was a poor idea for a few
reasons for one it made it difficult to
connect with the Japanese characters
especially young Atari since we're
always experiencing their point of view
through someone else and sometimes their
dialogue is actually drowned out
entirely and too if this film were rated
G or even PG this choice might make more
sense like for instance if Anderson was
assuming that children didn't want to
read subtitles but it's rated pg-13 and
is obviously aimed at older audiences so
the use of english-speaking interpreters
feels unnecessary because it adds
nothing artistically to the film there's
also a subplot with a foreign exchange
student played by Greta Gerwig that
feels useless that did little for the
story's movement besides these gripes
Isle of Dogs is a stunning animation
achievement Anderson's distinctive style
elevates an occasionally uneven story
and his brilliant cast of actors lend
their considerable talents to some
remarkable characters that in the end
have unexpectedly moving backstories I'm
always happy to see animation aimed at
adults
that's something I've pushed for on this
channel since the beginning I hope that
Hollywood continues to give us more
mature themes stories like this in
animation form I'm gonna give Isle of
Dogs a B+ guys thank you so much as
always for watching this review I will
have more coming your way very soon as
always you are the best and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]